[Music]
this is a school for young girls and
boys in afghanistan's capital of kabul
determined to learn students write the
day's lessons on a whiteboard in a
school without a roof
islam
i urge the islamic emirates to prepare
our class it's been six years since
we've had chairs tables books notebooks
and shade to sit under we also want to
become something in the future and
develop our country
the teachers and students say they lack
proper facilities and resources but
their complaints particularly those
coming from women they say are being
ignored
afghanistan's taliban rulers are holding
what's known as a loyal jirga a
three-day event attended by scholars and
clerics from around the country it's the
first such gathering since they retook
power in august last year
the issue of school girls is a challenge
and needs to be solved by the government
the government has the responsibility to
listen to the people's demands
more than 3 000 people are in the
capital for the event
it's being held in kabul's loya jirga
hall a traditional afghan place and way
of having the grievances of local
leaders heard but not one woman is
allowed to attend
this is something that
taliban don't believe to women's rights
that they think their ideology their
mindset is that women should stay at
home and do the house jewels and just
taking care of children and to make food
for them for uh for man and for them so
that's why they don't believe to women's
rights and and and it was the reason
that they didn't uh invite or they
didn't have any women
inside the loyalty the united states and
majority of the international community
have shunned the taliban government
demanding it be more inclusive and
respectful of women's rights the meeting
in kabul comes at a time when taliban
leaders face humanitarian and economic
catastrophes
jillian wolf al jazeera